I think the first question I have for
you is what is your earliest memory of
this of being involved auditioning or
when did you realize you were going to
be in this film and and how many films
had you been in before this or what well
I had been in four films already so I
guess I was considered a veteran I
started when I was four years old you
got the hard part I had to be sick and
it really mean it so that was it was a
very fun in those days you know we did
interviews and it was one-on-one and I
remember interviewing with mr. capper he
picked he picked every one of us I think
personally and I walked in there and did
my thing and he liked me and I got the
job Jimmy how about you I'd done a few
films before at MGM and the the most
vivid memories I had was getting up real
early in the morning about four or five
o'clock and was still dark and then we
took streetcars and buses to Culver City
- and then we walked on the stage 14
over there and this beautiful house was
there with this great Christmas tree and
the snow outside and it was quite a
thrill to see and because it was 90
degrees outside when we were yeah
getting there but I have wonderful visit
so which lot was this on that Culver
City over say oh okay Culver City age 14
okay and test where all the sets on
stage 14 and they rotate them out or it
was that where the house was that was a
house right yes Carol how about you well
I excuse me I have a my memory is
beginning to go so excuse me but I have
really neat memories of going on
interviews even though I was very
apprehensive and shy but the first thing
I had to do was to be able to play the
piano and I was very blessed that my
mother was able to give me lessons and I
guess he thought that I fit right into
the family picture I had no idea what
the what the plot was going to be or
anything but I was always very grateful
to get parts because I'm not a victim
but a person that went through the
depression depression thank you see how
sisters helping another I'll cover your
name anyway yes I was definitely a
depression baby my father was in the
stock market up in Canada and he just he
lost everything and so mother said well
I've got these children I had a brother
a little older than I myself and he said
that's I think we'll go out to
California and see if I can't get them
in pictures and so she I mean this brave
lady she just took my brother and I out
and she somehow I knew to go to Culver
City and she asked around how do I get
my kids in pictures so I went started
going on interviews and I was so
fortunate to go on the interview for
this film with Frank Capra and I don't
know about them but we I remember very
vividly on this part or just meeting mr.
caproni but what a wonderful person
really was any the main thing is I had
to have been able to play the piano well
thank God I had had some lessons and I
could play and boy did I practice but I
know it may not have seemed like it and
I'm not much better today and we have a
piano what the what an excuse anyway
I enjoyed meeting him and just working
with him he's a wonderful man